et maintenant nous pouvons partir avec
au fond de nos coeurs l'assurance que
que crée tonnes sera toujours
tu es
j'appelle
je peux vous aider ouais cherche une
petite fille avec une robe rouge
il est là votre petit ange
oh ça va ça va tout va bien je peux
t'aider
qu'est-ce qui se passerait
on s'y connaît en herbe je m'assure que
tu restes tu as ta place
quel gars
tu peux jouer avec moi
quand on regarde le diable en face on
doit s'attendre à en payer le prix
pas de pitié
tu es complètement siphonné du cadran
pas mal
bon ça s'ils essayent de mental et ses
escaliers tu lui tire dessus
combien de cartes où je vous avais une
seule